foreign
for much of the 20th century language
was seen as Central to our understanding
of the world the limits of my language
mean the limits of my world argued
Wittgenstein there's nothing outside of
the text claimed derida but now it seems
that language is being jettisoned by
philosophers as either containing
puzzles that are insoluble or irrelevant
to the real issues facing us the
American philosopher Hillary Putnam went
as far to say that the project described
the relationship between the language
between language and the world is a
shambles
so should we conclude that the puzzle of
language and its relation to the world
is not solvable or is it essential we
crack the problem and not give up or
should we focus not on the medium but
the message and return to an era before
the so-called linguistic term when
language was largely seen as a
transparent vehicle of our beliefs so
the critical question that I'm going to
present first to Ruth kempson for three
minutes is is the puzzle of language and
its relation to the world fundamentally
unsolvable Ruth thank you well I'm a
linguist so I have to answer the
question is the language puzzle not
solvable with the answer no
it is solvable however I wholeheartedly
agree that conventional views of
language of making a dichotomy between
language ability and language use have
to be abandoned and the concept of
language as a set of it's constantly
seen as a sort of jigsaw puzzle from God
on high looking it down at these bits
which have fixed meanings which have to
get put together that also has to be
abandoned the shift is to see language
as a process it's a tool for interaction
its rules being conditional actions as
to how to build up representations of
content incrementally think of what
you're doing right now relative to an
immediate and evolving context this is
the way we Define language all the way
down we have General procedures
anticipating structure and words too are
defined as routine eyes conditional
update actions relative to context we're
always building as we go fast
now these are shared by speaker and hero
alike on this view so in effect we're
incrementally building stuff together in
tandem there's no syntax on this this is
what the grammar amounts to that's us
now the consequence is that what others
have seen as disfluences of conversation
we're all told by linguists
conversations are full of Errors people
don't know what they're doing you can
just ignore the mistakes but once you
shift to languages process then in fact
all these mechanisms that we have to
confirm to correct to interrupt they're
all part of the tools for interaction
which we can use in order to come to
successful exchanges
so communication succeeds as long as the
overlap we have in our underlying
assumptions are sufficient for the
purpose to hand and if they're not we
can always query and clarify but it's
not always in harmony but in virtue of
me going blah blah are you listening to
the blah blah we are in effect
interacting well we hope so with the
questions and answers
and these interactive capacities they're
all an intrinsic part of what it means
to have language as a processing tool
and so it follows that the
correspondence in answer the question
the correspondence between language in
the world has to be secondary and
moreover it has to be approximate now
there's much more to be said because
it's critical that words are not
associated with fixed correspondences
there may are labels pointing in the
direction of putative construals given
the immediate context of other words
occurring in the context and that's what
we need and what we think we can model
now I'm actually going to shift now and
ask instead how on Earth could the
linguist have got to this point and the
answer is that I was trying to do things
for my friends who are pragmatists and
they wanted I thought they needed a
model of how we actually build up
structure into promote understanding in
context and I knew I couldn't do it on
my own so I turned to logicians and
computationists but the result of it was
that we had this view of building up
things incrementally and one after
another all the puzzles which
syntacticians or semanticists had fell
into our laps where for other Frameworks
they all have to be stipulated with huge
amounts of ad hoc and block structures
and so we decided it was a grammar
adopted by both speakers and hear it now
if that is correct if as an assumption
it has the immediate consequence that we
can interact that the phenomena of
conversational interaction comes as an
immediate consequence because I can
start off and you can finish the
sentence you might want to disagree with
me but that's fine I can start and you
can take over now that is completely
impossible to express in standard
Orthodox views of grammar they just have
to ignore it and in fact they do but
there's much more to say about the
intrinsic non-determinism and then I'm
going to I'm going to not do that but
I'm going to stop and say just this in
order to Define language as a system of
tools with flexibility to operate in an
evolving context which we're all doing
all the time then it's concepts of
process under determinism change growth
those are the central underpinnings to
explanation of not just what language is
about but what language is and that's
what we call Dynamic syntax thanks very
much
well yeah spot on thank you very much
thank you yes flaws for that too
thank you and I'll now turn to Hillary
Lawson with the same question Hillary so
the question again is is the puzzle of
language and its relation to the world
fundamentally unsolvable thank you well
I think if by a solution we mean that we
might provide a map of how language
relates to the world I think the answer
is no
I don't think it's possible to provide a
map of how language relates to the world
and for a very straightforward reason a
reason that Wittgenstein identified
right at the outset of the linguistic
term
which is that and it's relatively easily
expressed really it's that
uh
you can't escape the language in order
to describe how it relates to something
which is outside of language
after all another way of putting it
would be to say the words language and
the world
are words in language aren't they
the word the world hasn't escaped from
language it it it it it doesn't somehow
get at the world it's a word in language
so you can't from within language
say what the relationship is between
language and something outside of it
because any account you give is going to
be in the context of language so he
concluded we just can't say anything
about that relationship
now
I think one way of thinking about what's
going on here is that to ask what is the
relationship between language in the
world is a bit like asking what's the
relationship between cabbages and
bicycles
well the best answer is there isn't a
relationship
rather than to try and provide one which
is uh exceptionally tricky because there
isn't one in the first place
and it seems to me that there isn't a
relationship between language and the
world in the sense that language is not
describing the world I agreed with much
of things that Ruth was saying but I
would actually go a bit further I don't
think that language is approximating to
reality I think it's got nothing to do
with it and
um
the challenge for contemporary
philosophy is not to describe the
relationship between language and the
world but to count for how it is that
even though language doesn't have
anything to do with reality
or or let's stick to the word world
actually it doesn't have anything to do
to do with the world that nevertheless
it is so powerful and it's able to
seemingly describe things so precisely
and that we can share it to talk to or
to talk about what seems to be a shared
reality and that seems to me to be the
central puzzle it's one I've spent a lot
of time thinking about and in in an
instantaneous sort of indication of the
sort of answer that I'm going to offer
to you that I would say instead of
thinking of language as describing the
world think of language as holding the
world as something
and by holding the world as something we
intervene on the basis of holding it
like that and we can refine that way of
holding the world based on how it seems
from when in that model within that
theoretical framework and we can refine
it ever more accurately but it never
gets to be like stuff out there because
it can never reach out there it's a
different sort of stuff
and um but nevertheless it can be
immensely uh powerful and so think of
language as a metaphor by which we can
achieve all sorts of extraordinary
things but not as describing how things
are in some ultimate sense thanks very
much Hillary thank you
[Applause]
and so now I'll pose the same question
to rfomed is the puzzle of language and
its relation to the world fundamentally
unsolvable thank you thank you thank you
so much um I think my comments will
largely be agreeing with with some of
the things that Ruth kempson has has
said
um I think I'll actually say three
things so first of all I'll say I'll
make a comment on what Hillary just said
uh and then I'll say something about a
couple of misconceptions that I think
can exist about this about this problem
but first of all my answer is no it's
not insoluble it is it is soluble um
one thing I would say is that I think
there might be they might be mistaken
thinking that somehow the fact that like
the fact that we're talking about
language means that we can't actually
describe it fully in language as though
you can't use language to talk about
itself it's true that Wittgenstein
sometimes seems to have had ideas like
that in his early work but it's not
obvious why any of that should be true I
mean after all you can write about
handwriting in handwriting you could say
something about the English language in
English and it's not clear there's
anything you can't say about it in
English that you could say in another
language so it's not obvious why this
sort of reflexivity
um uh eye-catching as it is raises any
insoluble problems for the project of
understanding language either
scientifically or in a more sort of
philosophical way if there's a
difference
the other two things I want to say first
of all I guess is that we should be
skeptical that there is a single problem
which is about the relationship between
one thing called language and another
thing called the world Vikings fan
himself wrote not in his earlier work
but in his later work um he emphasized
the fact that languages like games come
in a very large variety of things there
may be no one thing in common but in all
the different linguistic all the
different behavioral phenomena that we
call language so if you just think in
the in the case of words if you think
about words were used to describe
people's mental States words like
conditionals or pronouns or words
describing causation all the words for
relations all the variety of words that
we have in our language there's no
particular reason to think that they
should all function in the same way or
that we can say anything very useful in
general about how all of them work
similarly you might there's no one
relationship between language in the
world but rather there are many
different relationships between this bit
of language and this bit of the world
and that bit of language and that bit of
the world and we can say how these words
are used this picks up on one of the
things that Ruth kempson emphasized
um in a piecemeal way which is
nonetheless scientific
the third thing I want to say I guess is
just to emphasize that of course
languages is like anything because it's
not magic it's not some sort of
metaphysical achievement it's a natural
phenomenon and it grew out of natural
phenomena their animals have some things
like languages so animals have various
cries that have evolved into language we
can see why language would exist simply
the from the fact that we need to be
able to signal to each other in various
situations and some philosophers like
David Lewis and others have seen
languages arise from the sort of Game
Theory type situations where you're
trying to signal to someone else about
something in a state of ignorance of the
other person's in a state of Icarus they
can explain a great deal about how
language works and what it illustrates
more importantly is that language just
like everything else in the world is a
part of Nature and should be studied as
a part of Nature and not as some
additional metaphysical achievement uh
that somehow achieves some kind of magic
that we're incapable of understanding
thank you thanks very much Harris thank
you
thank you
to watching this video click the link in
the top left or in the description below
or visit iai.tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas